so there is a renewed and re-energized
Peto or Roarke running around out there
he's running for the Democratic
nomination in 2020 it's not going super
well Beto is polling two to three
percent in his latest post second debate
polls his first debate performance was
atrocious
but betta was on fire this week I told
you earlier this week that Beto was
finally speaking sort of more from the
heart he wasn't using these calculated
talking points and he was speaking
earlier this week about the El Paso
shooting very clearly and very precisely
drawing a connective line between Donald
Trump's rhetoric and the shooting and
now he straight-up called Donald Trump a
white supremacist on live television
take a look at this clip you've been
very clear that you believe the
president is a racist is the president a
white supremacist he is he's also made
that very clear he's dehumanized or
sought to do dehumanize those who do not
look like or pray like the majority here
in this country he said I wish we had
more immigrants from Nordic countries
because those from Haiti bring aids
those from Africa come from [ __ ]
nations he's been very clear about who
he prefers to be in this country and who
he literally wants to keep out with
walls and cages and militarization and
torture and cruelty and and again we and
El Paso have borne the brunt of all of
that but we in El Paso are standing up
to all that right now and I've never
been more proud of this community than I
am at this moment I don't really know if
Trump is a white supremacist he's
certainly fomenting and coalescing and
encouraging white supremacy but this is
a great new Beto I said it Monday and
I'll repeat it today if this had been
the Beto we'd been seeing all along he
might be polling better than 2 or 3
percent I mean it's really a breath of
fresh air in a world riddled with
calculated talking points and hedging on
everything and from what I understand
there are people around Beto I don't
know if official campaign people or just
people that he talks to who are
cautioning him about saying that certain
things so bluntly politicians are
supposed to you don't have caveats and
speak in vague language that failed Beto
completely the calculated milquetoast
bullet points have completely failed him
and left him in a losing position in
this primary
it's probably too late already to
actually help him recover but maybe not
he has qualified for the third debate
the tell-it-like-it-is
version of Beto is absolutely the way to
go and in fact this is the version of
Beto that almost saw him take out an
incumbent Republican senator in the red
state of Texas Ted Cruz he ultimately
did lose but not by much and it was
close because it was genuine tell it
like it is say what's on your mind Beto
and it's really just kind of sad that
telling it like it is in normal speech
is this notable for a politician Beto
was asked a question he answered it
clearly with a yes or no he supported it
with examples and you can say well it's
easier now for Beto to just let it fly
and to behave this way because he no
longer has anything to lose cuz he's
polling two percent you may be right
about what has inspired the change maybe
it is that he feels like he has nothing
else to lose it could just be that he is
genuinely affected by what's been going
on in El Paso because that is where he's
from but it's a sad commentary on the
political environment either way
whatever the reasons are I'm glad to see
this bet oh and by the way whatever you
think about white supremacists
as a term for Donald Trump corporate
media won't even call Trump a liar we've
talked about this before corporate media
will say when Trump has strayed from the
facts when Trump has not been accurate
in the things that he has said times the
president didn't tell the whole truth
and from what I understand there are
legal reasons why many corporate media
outlets stopped short of just straight
up calling Donald Trump a liar but it
would really be great if it wasn't so
rare to just call things what they are
and I'm actually I'm not you know people
know that my politics are more in line
with Bernie's or with Elizabeth Warren's
for example not necessarily better or
Roarke but I hope that this Beddoe
continues I hope that this is the better
that we see in the September 12th or
12th and 13th debates I guess depending
on how many people are left in the race
at that point in time because this
actual
is a bet oh that might inspire rather
than confuse and sort of just make
people wonder what is it that he even
really stands for it feels too
calculated it feels too focus-grouped in
some way let's hope that it continues
and he by the way speaking of a
politician just speaking from the heart
and telling it like it is I was able to
watch more of Bernie's appearance on the
Joe Rogan experience yesterday a bunch
of people on my twitch stream yesterday
said you really got to check it out it
was really good and I know that so
there's this like never-ending battle
not to go completely off script here
proverbially but there's this
never-ending battle about should the
left appear on Joe Rogan's show because
he allows so many right-wing talking
points to be parotid uninterrupted or
should left.this avoid Joe Rogan's show
I think the answer is very clear anybody
who goes on Joe Rogan's program is going
to be giving an operative in' an
opportunity to sort of flesh out their
ideas with only mild resistance or
pushback from Joe like that's the format
and he pushed back on things I said a
little bit when I was on his program
back in June and he pushed back a little
bit with Bernie but what was fantastic
about Bernie's appearance which was only
I think like 50 67 minutes long or
something like that what was great about
it is that Joe provided you could argue
that it was not enough or too much
depending on your politics but he
provided an amount of pushback to Bernie
that was enough of for Bernie to be able
to come right back with counter points
that in that environment were very very
strong fantastic appearance for Bernie
Sanders on the program I don't know if
it's you know enough to move polling for
Bernie but it's certainly enough to
generate donations for Bernie which
unfortunately in the money in politics
status quo system that we have makes a
difference and I think it was completely
worthwhile for Bernie to do it